hier soir didier rahout interviewé sur
bfmtv c'est tous les jours un médiateur
jean il est tous les jours
invité sur bet didier raoult sauf qu'à
un moment le professeur s'est encore
lâché la journaliste marc godefroy ville
était en train de lui poser une question
et d'un coup qu'il a montré son
agacement il nous a fait ce qu'on
appelle dans le milieu une finkielkraut
regarde et vous pas eu le temps de faire
les deux du soin et de l'argent mais
parce que vous aviez une super record de
3500 patients qui auraient pu faire un
groupe en pétrole comme ça on aurait
1500 naturelle de la maladie mais il
faut chercher et vous me posez une
question de rapport utilisez vous m'avez
posé une question en racontant week end
même moi mais je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec lui et parce qu'on voit
très bien que la journaliste allait
poser une question accusatrice donc hâte
dans tous les moments à un moment donné
quand quand quand elle abusée qu elle
insisté qu'elle le soul il lui dit chum
taisez vous c'est quelqu'un de naturel
ils disent qu'ils pensent gilles suis
pas du tout d'accord avec elisha
marouflé ses limites mais dix ans est
mauvaise et agressif
la reine a été agréé son boulot elle
fait son boulot elle pose la question
mais comment puis je vous dire quand on
invite quelqu'un je voulais arrêter de
l'attaqué chacun respecte il vient tout
le temps plus ce didier raoult c'était
fr il est sympa de venir arrêter d'achat
fois de l'attaqué je suis désolé excusez
moi oui j'irai moi je n'ai pas pris
comme ça je les prie autrement je les
prises sur le fait qu'elle lui pose une
question
lui veut répondre à cherbourg parce
qu'il a la réponse elle enchaîne arrête
pas de parler c'était leur pose une
autre question et lui taisez-vous parce
que j'ai déjà la question à vous reste
que c'était qu'il y en a déjà posé une
je vais déjà répondre à la question et
ensuite je répondre à votre question
après c'est pas la classe et on a obtenu
à lille elle n'avait pas obtenu la bonne
réponse qu'elle attendait en revanche
que je reproche à ce point vous êtes un
très grand infectiologues ça on peut pas
le nier il est magnifique
ce que je reproche qui doit être plus
dans la pédagogie comme les médecins
doivent l'être que et moins dans la
démagogie il n'arrête pas de faire des
interviews maintenant ils essaient de se
dédouaner de son histoire qu'au début
c'est un médecin c'était juste une
grippette ont nettement pas les
pédagogistes actionnant ses intimes
magnifique c'est qu'il sait surtout que
l'été frappé du syndrome michel cymes et
passent plus de temps la télématique à
l'hôpital c'est quand même des bureaux
il y fait des soldats je pense avoir sa
popularité mais il aurait pas de
l'argent ou non ils ont fait pas de
l'argent comme ça toute la journée c'est
vrai qu'il fait pas d'argent à la raison
qu'elle y fait pas des listes derrière
c'est pas des trucs